hey this is presto Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
fun puzzle I received by email ABC is
equal to a factorial plus B factorial
plus C factorial
none of the digits is equal to zero and
you need to solve for the three-digit
number
a B C while you Mull on this problem
let's go to the you feature me I feature
you segment where I think people who
have shared my videos PopSugar had an
article this math brain teaser is way
harder than it looks
can you figure it out do check out that
article and also check out my video so
returning to this puzzle can you figure
out ABC give it a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution so how can we solve this
problem
well get started by listing out the
factorial of each number starting at one
by the time we get to seven factorial
there's something to notice since seven
factorial is a four-digit number 5040
and we need a three-digit number ABC
that means we cannot have seven as a
digit it's too large similarly we cannot
have eight or nine as digits because
eight factorial and nine factorial are
even larger values now consider could
six be a digit while if six was a digit
then the resulting number would be
larger than six factorial which equals
720 but then we would need a to be equal
to seven eight or nine which is not
possible because we just excluded those
digits thus we cannot have six as a
digit either so at this point we've
concluded we cannot have six seven eight
or nine
as did
now consider four factorial if a B and C
only had digits of four or smaller then
the largest sum we could produce is four
factorial plus four factorial plus four
factorial which equals 72 but this is
too small
we need a three-digit number so in order
to form a three-digit number we must
have at least one digit be equal to five
so we'll add that to our findings at
least one digit must be equal to five
now consider five factorial which equals
120 we can check that 555 is not a valid
solution so that means we can have at
most two digits equal to 5 with 2 digits
equal to 5 we can then check the
possible sums and see that none of these
produce possible solutions if we have
two digits of 5 and we check the other
digit of 1 to 3 or 4 we don't produce a
three-digit number that involves 2 fives
so we conclude exactly one digit is
equal to 5 now what can we do from here
the largest sum we can produce is 5
factorial plus 4 factorial plus 4
factorial which equals 168 this means
the digit a has to be equal to 1 so
we're almost there we have 2 possible
cases to consider we could have the
number being 1/5 B or it could be 1 B 5
we can check each of these cases because
B can either be 1 2 3 or 4 in the 1 5 B
case we see that none of these are of
the form 1 5 B but these exact sums
could be of the form 1 B 5 and in fact
the very last equation 1 factorial plus
4 factorial plus 5 factorial produces
the result of 145 and this exactly works
so there you go ABC is equal to a
factorial plus B factorial plus C
factorial we get the result 145 is equal
to 1
factorial plus four factorial plus five
factorial and this is the only solution
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video these math videos
which can be watched for free inspire
and build confidence for people around
the world and they already have over a
hundred million views with your help we
can share the beauty of mathematics and
make the world a better place for you
and for me and the entire human race
please subscribe for free to get the
newest videos watch and share all of
mind your decisions videos you can email
me a puzzle or mat topic at presh at
mind your decisions comm and if you so
choose you can check out my books which
are listed in the video description and
you can support me on patreon to earn
exclusive rewards thanks for watching
and thanks for your support